what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we have some new details
exclusive details coming from Empire
magazine about Adam Warlock including
our first full look at his entire
character in the first teaser trailer
that we got for the Guardians of the
Galaxy vol 3 we only kind of got a
glimpse at him
but here he is in this exclusive Empire
magazine look in his full Glory Will
Poulter of course is the actor who was
playing Adam Warlock who a lot of people
were very let's say nervous about most
people knew him as the scrawny kid from
the We're the Millers movie or the
eyebrows kid depending on what you call
them but now he's all buffed up and he
looks pretty dang good well right away
let us know what you think about him in
the comments down below now this
exclusive Empire magazine article gives
us of course some exclusive details
about his character coming straight from
James Gunn himself so of course we're
going to dive into this article and
break it on down but just so everybody
is aware Empire magazine has been giving
us some teases and some exclusive photos
and info about things coming up in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe but the full
article about Guardians volume 3 and
Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania goes on
sale to the public in a few days on
Thursday January 19th so look out for
that and look out for our breakdown on
that as well but for now sticking with
Adam Warlock let's take a look at this
Empire magazine article it starts off by
saying ever since a certain cocoon
appeared as an Easter egg and Thor the
Dark world's post-credit sequence Marvel
fans have been waiting for the emergence
of Adam Warlock in the MCU the ultra
powerful Cosmic entity later got a more
official tee up for his upcoming big
screen debut soon to arrive in James
gunz's long-awaited three-quil Guardians
of the Galaxy Vol 3. as established in
volume 2 gold huge Sovereign leader
Aisha created him and it does say here
in a different cocoon the previous one
is no longer Canon but she created him
to take down our favorite group of
Intergalactic a-holes the Guardians
themselves after they double-crossed her
so that is important to note the Easter
egg 4 Adam warlock's cocoon and Thor the
Dark World is no longer Canon so we
simply ignore that now but I think a lot
of people ignore Thor the Dark World
anyways so all good But continuing on
with what James Gunn teases is for Adam
Warlock the article says get ready then
for an incoming comic book favorite
whose literal raisin ditra which simply
just means reason for being is to take
our heroes down or perhaps not as James
Gunn teases he says it's kind of more
complicated than that and here's where
we get some good details about him he
says but he's definitely not a good guy
what we're seeing is the infant form of
warlock newly out of the Cocoon and he
does not understand life very well he's
basically a baby now he teases more but
let's talk about this first part because
it just makes sense we know that Adam
Warlock is supposed to be a good guy
he's actually probably one of the most
well-known superheroes and favorites of
comic book fans it's kind of hard not to
love a guy who straight up punches
Thanos right in the face plus not to
mention in the comics he has the soul
gem now clearly that is not going to be
the case here in the MCU as the Infinity
Stones have been destroyed but he still
does have a gym in his forehead but
moving on from that he is going to be
just a baby is what James Gunn confirms
granted he is a very jacked baby and is
probably still going to be just as
powerful but this explains how he's
going to be the villain at first most of
us assume since the Sovereign and Aisha
created him he would simply follow her
orders her orders to take out the
Guardians of the Galaxy which since she
is basically his mom he would do however
he's going to come out fully formed his
body will be just as you see it right
here muscles fully developed and he's
going to be ultra strong so he's going
to be a huge threat to the Guardians
however since he's going to be a baby
he's not going to really know why so the
big question was always well how is he
going to turn good and it looks like he
is simply going to grow up now since the
Sovereign are all about Evolution I'm
assuming that he's going to grow up
relatively fast like by the end of the
movie so I'm assuming that by the end of
the movie he is going to be good but
James Gunn actually teases this he
teases warlock actually going on to be
critical hero in the MCU let's talk
about this the article continues as
babies go he's a physically imposing one
arriving in the form of a beefed up Will
Poulter the six foot three Brit who
Beyond popping up and Johnny Flynn Indie
flick the score was last seen on the big
screen meeting a sticky end of the hands
of Harga in mid-summer James Gunn says
people online were saying oh Tom Cruise
should be out of warlock I wanted
somebody who was youthful and I wanted
the person who had the dramatic chops
and the comedic chops not only for this
movie but for what Marvel will use out
of warlock for it in the future and then
James Gunn says he could become this
really important character now I do like
that Adam Warlock is going to be
somewhat funny in this movie of course
it's James Gunn and the Guardians of the
Galaxy you have to have the same humor
although this movie does seem to be a
lot more dramatic than the last two but
James Gunn wanted somebody youthful and
we all get it now he wanted Adam Warlock
to be somewhat like a baby so a young
younger version of Adam Warlock who of
course will grow in the MCU and since
James Gunn teased that he's going to be
a very important character I'm assuming
he's not going anywhere but this
essentially tells us how Adam Warlock is
going to eventually be good it's going
to be one of those things where you kind
of realize that your parents aren't all
that good and I believe this is going to
come by simply him asking the question
why why am I destroying the Guardians of
the Galaxy why do you hate the Guardians
of the Galaxy and if it all comes down
to Rocket stealing a couple of batteries
I'm not sure Adam Warlock is going to be
down with that especially after probably
getting to know them a little bit in the
movie but here's actually what I think
could really sway Adam Warlock and I'm
not sure how fans are going to like this
some of the comic book fans may already
be thinking what I'm thinking because in
the comics Adam Warlock and Gamora are
an item they're together they're in a
relationship and since we have a new
Gamora in the MCU right now specifically
in our Earth 616 Universe I'm thinking
that this still might indeed be an
option we know that this new Gamora is
indeed going to be helping the Guardians
of the Galaxy perhaps she is why Adam
Warlock becomes good because he sees
this Gamora and experiences feelings for
her and doesn't want to kill her now
this would obviously create a very
complicated and messy situation with
Star-Lord and of course the Guardians of
the Galaxy Star-Lord loves Gamora but
this Gamora doesn't love Star-Lord and
there's no guarantee that they're going
to continue that route and have the new
Gamora eventually fall in love with
Star-Lord so it could be that they go a
completely different route and simply
have Adam Warlock and Gamora get
together just like what happens in the
comics but as sad as it is there's also
no guarantee that Star-Lord or Gamora is
going to make it out alive out of this
movie because we know that the real
villain of this movie is the high
evolutionary the person who created
Rocket Raccoon now I don't think that
rocket is going to die in this movie it
seems a little bit too obvious by the
trailers but I'm pretty sure everybody
thinks Drax is going to die perhaps
mantis although I hope not but what if
Star-Lord dies it would be terrible and
I absolutely would not like that to
happen but anything is really possible
here and that would kind of clear up
some room for Adam Warlock and Gamora to
get together in this universe but we'll
have to wait and see on that now as far
as the high evolutionary goes I believe
as I've mentioned before that he could
possibly be in charge of the Sovereign
The Sovereign is all about Evolution and
so is the high evolutionary in fact they
could be some of his subjects we know
that he experiments on animals turning
them into humanoid forms like Rocket
Raccoon and much like the people that
we've seen in the trailer on counter
Earth this could explain how the high
evolutionary gets involved and I think
that he might have made a deal with
Aisha stating that if Adam Warlock
brings him Rocket Raccoon who escaped
from him he'll let her do whatever she
wants with the rest of the Guardians of
the Galaxy because we know that Adam
Warlock kidnaps Rocket Raccoon from
nowhere based off of what we've heard
but we also know that the high
evolutionary once rocket because he
escapes so a deal can be struck between
the two of them and this is why it's
going to be extremely hard for the
Guardians of the Galaxy in this film
they have to fight fight Adam Warlock
The Sovereign and the high evolutionary
who has an army of his own so it won't
be easy and if you have a thought on
who's not gonna make it out alive be
sure to let us know Down Below in the
comments but in the meantime also let us
know what you think about Will Poulter
as Adam Warlock I hope you like him
because it looks like he's going to be
sticking around for a pretty long time
and the MCU and it's going to be a
pretty important character but let us
know your thoughts in the comments down
below don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
all things relating to the MCU for live
updates you can follow us on Instagram
and Twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching woof woof
me